all right so we had two correspondents
at the trump rally over the weekend in
conroe texas we had luke beasley down
there and we had josh pitt and these
guys did a fantastic job we're going to
look at some of these videos now
this is the worst of the worst of what
we suspected was going on at these
rallies in terms of the people i put
together some questions for luke and
josh you can find by the way if you go
to youtube and search for luke beasley
luke has a youtube channel uh make sure
to subscribe he's really doing a great
job uh so let's start i mean let's let's
just jump right into it
um
the first guy that luke spoke to
um admitted to going to the capitol on
january 6 2021.
i
plain and simple let's just jump right
into it and
account for the fact that there's a
there's background noise it was a wild
and raucous situation uh some of the
audio is not perfect but the guys did
the best job they could here is one guy
saying i was at the capitol on january
6th so you're here on the trump rally
what are you opening
up on stage
you know i just want to i hope we have a
plan to get this uh get our republic
back that's what i'm here for i'm trying
to find my son he's in this big crowd
here we go we were
in washington on january 6th with two
million patriots now of course there
were not first of all i would argue that
they're not patriots but that putting
that aside there were not too many
million people in washington on january
6. that's widely known now
and i'm happy to be here i walk about
three miles to get to this field imagine
walking three miles to go to a trump
rally dang tell me you didn't
oh my goodness yeah that's crazy no it
was uh it was it was a great day until
the end
for sure
so there is a guy who admits that he
went to the capitol um two of the
questions that i told the guys we should
really ask are ask people what they
think about critical race theory
and then if they say their whatever they
say about it then ask them what is
critical race theory i also told them to
ask about socialism
it's basically as good as we could have
imagined um they're very much against
critical race theory
and they don't know what it is here's
josh pitt
talking to
the first guy and again i know there's
background audio we should we i think we
can still make out what's being said
here the questions are
what do you think about critical race
theory what is critical race theory
think about critical race
what do you think of critical race
theory i'm not a fan
what is critical race theory not what
i'm a fan of
none of them know what it is shouldn't
surprise us here's another one
gotcha are you concerned with critical
race i think absolutely it's that again
it could be hot no yeah it is being
taught and some some schools some
schools are fighting it so it's not
there yet but i can guarantee you around
the united states it's in schools at a
very young age and it's very sad
so it's terrible that it's being taught
including to kids at a young age
it will change this whole country what
is critical risk what is critical risk
theory criteria is a lot of things i've
not done a lot of research on it but
there's a lot of things in it
the uh total race-baiting
uh teachings the uh help me out by the
uh lgbtq uh
lgb qua that's interesting i have never
heard
critical race theory be called lgb quoi
but i mean listen uh this this is
someone who is very much against it
yeah they're teaching sex education to
the kids i mean there's just all kinds
of stuff now sex education has nothing
to do with critical race theory but i'm
sure you guys know that
with it i'm not good on that because i
can't like give it but yes
okay um then there were a lot of people
this is something huh a lot of people
furious with mike pence
and in fact we are now looking at a guy
holding a sign that says execute pence
for treason
uh let's listen a little bit here
he could have stopped it
[Music]
so
what just happened is this guy is
holding a sign that says execute pence
and then another guy yells that clinton
should be executed in a public square
this line order people
don't care about due process go figure
are you
[Music]
so now we move on to
my next question which is is joe biden a
socialist or communist and i made sure
that the guys know if they say yes
you've got to ask what are the socialist
or communist policies and again it's
exactly what we expected he needs to be
in prison
sorry or hung like back in the day but
you know
that that rule has kind of changed
oh sorry and we need to we need to
actually move up to the uh so the
communism part is just a few a moment
ahead here uh okay here we go finding my
there's just so much here
so do you think joe biden is communist
yes
yes yes he's so up in the china is not
even funny so based on what policy that
he supports would you consider to be
communist
what what do you mean
isn't that the best on the basis of
which policy is joe biden a communist
sorry what do you mean
well it's kind of the key question ma'am
are there any policies that he's enacted
or supported
well he supports china and that just
sums it all up right there
he supports the chinese he's been in
their pockets and that's not going to
change so this woman thinks biden's a
communist because he supports china
i believe so this now we've got another
guy and if you're not watching this guy
is wearing full trump regalia it's a
trump hat
a trump jersey
a trump cape and a trump flag and here's
this guy's explanation as to why biden
is a communist
a weak
communist we
wake up
to be against covenants you know we can
fight for america
for americans using
weak
american foods
okay um
then we ask people are they vaccinated
um most of them were not
um
[Music]
and i want my immune system and i'll
fast make that even stronger i didn't
know that you could fast
to to do something about covid not
eating
to deal with covet is i've not heard
that before
absolutely not and my son's not and
nobody is going to be
oh and then lastly
we go back to this guy who explains why
global warming isn't real and he's
talking about something related to
planets around the sun
one oven
right every three months
in flight in the universe
is a different section right so so
the big object
each season the earthquake
travels in the universe
one one
so each region in the universe is
different right
and how do you change that
you got to pray to god i guess what he's
saying is there's no global warming
because
earth is moving through
the universe
and
climate changes as a result and all you
can really do to control it i guess is
pray pray to god so
as bad as anything we imagined
a major success great job by luke
beasley and josh pitt and great job by
producer pat putting all of that
together and we're going to do that
again we'll keep sending people to these
rallies and
your memberships help pay for us being
able to do that we'll let you know when
the next rally is upcoming
your internet traffic can be observed by
a number of people your internet service
provider big tech platforms even by the
government and that's why i protect my
internet connection with atlas vpn which
hides my ip address making me invisible
to these intermediaries on the internet
who can track me and sell my data i also
use atlas vpn to watch shows on netflix
and hulu only available in other
countries but the privacy aspect is
what's most important to me if you're
not using a vpn
read about it read about why they're so
important and with just one atlas vpn
account i can protect all of my devices
at the same time you turn it on once you
forget about it you stay anonymous right
now atlas vpn is having a big sale for
my audience giving you 86
off this comes out to a dollar 39 a
month plus you'll get three months free
just click the link below and use the
code pacman